okay okay I know what it looks like but
here's the good news
oh here we go the multiverse didn't
collapse oh cool
it'll work down great story hey did you
finish the goober it's not a goober it's
a gizmo you always have to call me out
this is really frustrating impose don't
get too excited Miguel it's just a
protocol not excited but you could be
the first person to make an autonomous
multiverse jump or the last okay so
we're just gonna roll the dice on this
what do you say pal where do you want to
go first let's start at the beginning
one last time earth 67 I'm spider-man I
need you to come with me I just told you
that listen listen I'm from the future
how dare you point at me who you were
pointing first rude to point hey
everyone it's Charlie we have the best
possible news if you're a big fan of
spider-man they just announced that Lord
and Miller are doing a giant
interconnected TV universe of Sony
spider-man universe characters so we'll
explain what's going on what it's gonna
look like and what they've said about
how everything's gonna go down and we'll
talk about some of the big events that
they would do from the comics when they
actually do cross the characters over
we're doing the giveaway for the
spider-man far from home blu-ray all you
have to do to enter that is be a
subscriber and leave your best
spider-verse theory on the video so a
lot of you are like wait a minute
live-action spider-verse what's going on
they joked about doing a live-action
spider-verse movie while they were
promoting spider-man far from home any
pascal's like that would be amazing
getting Andrew Garfield and Tobey
Maguire's spider-man in a movie with Tom
Holland maybe that'll work out someday
but this is sort of a pie in the sky
dream I don't think that we actually
believe that they're gonna do anything
like that anytime soon it's just a dream
that big spider-man fans have am I'm not
supposed to have what I want
what I need but this live-action
interconnected series of TV shows with
spider-man characters is real they're
actually working on it right now most of
you are familiar with Lord and Miller
from at least something that they've
done they're mostly known as TV people
but they've been doing a lot of movies
stuff in the last couple of years too
they're responsible for all the lego
movies they were the producers on
spider-man into the spider-verse they
signed a giant deal with Sony Pictures
Television to develop projects for them
that means making movies for them
they're gonna continue to make more
spider-man into the spider-verse movies
they'll be spin-offs for those but also
developing TV shows for them too so the
actual news release reads like this TV
series based on the Marvel characters
that Sony controls that spider-man
characters if you guys didn't know that
as part of the rights that they owned
with a spider-man character they control
over 900 different characters but those
900 people all come from spider-man
comics that's how it works they have the
rights to the people from the spider-man
comics this is what the diagram looks
like after the Fox deal so you can see
now there used to be a bubble with like
the Fox characters over on the side
that's now part of this larger blob
where Marvel almost controls everything
save for some hook characters and Namor
that Universal still controls people are
wondering about the Namor movie
Universal only has the rights to release
movies with these characters Marvel has
the rights to use them in movies so like
Namor could be the villain in a black
panther movie but Marvel could not
release a name or solo movie the deal
that they have with Sony is a little bit
different where Sony has the rights to
release and make all those movies by
themselves but they signed the sharing
arrangement for the Tom Holland Peter
Parker with whatever characters that
Marvel wanted to put in those Tom
Holland movies and then all the other
spider-man characters that they had they
could do whatever they want to with
which is where you get to the venom
movie the animated spider-man into the
spider-verse movies and now all these
new live-action TV shows that they're
developing spider-man into the
spider-verse was a great movie Lord and
Miller a great creatives so I trust
whatever it is that they're going to do
but I will talk about my top 5 picks for
who is gonna get those TV shows who are
the main leads going to be which big
characters they did not say where all
the TV shows are gonna air they said
that they're gonna announce that pretty
soon but it could be on a streaming
networking could be Netflix it could be
Hulu it could be Disney Plus or it could
be some of the major networks - the way
they talked about connecting all these
spider-man TV shows makes it sound like
they are building up to their own
version of a crisis on Infinite Earths
arrowverse tops a crisis is imminent
someone is coming someone far far more
powerful than myself I mean to prepare
so when you're thinking about this
live-action Spiderman TV show universe
think about it the same way you think
about the arrow verse shows crossing
over they all have their own seasons but
then every once in a while they cross
over together in a really really big
story their quote reads we're figuring
out a way to develop the shows that are
each their own unique experience but are
also related so it's like all the arrow
verse shows try to be a little bit
different but when they cross over it
winds up being a big Avengers type of
event just like you saw during the
animated spider-man into the spider
burst movie where you have all these
versions of spider-man or Spider Woman
in the case of spider-gwen crossing over
and teaming up for a really big event
they said they're developing a handful
of shows how many does that mean that
means probably three to four different
shows us has this gonna work but what's
probably gonna happen is it's just like
the air over shows is they're gonna
start with one with their strongest
character and make sure that that show
is popular then once that's successful
do the second show then the third show
and so on and so forth till they get to
the fourth show they did tease that not
all the shows would be live-action so
there'll be a couple live-action shows
crossing over and one or two of them
would also be animated it'll make more
sense when I talk about some of these
characters because there are a ton of
really popular spider-verse characters
in not all them or as viable for
live-action as others some of them are
gonna wind up being so crazy that'll be
way too expensive to produce it would
just make more sense to turn them into
animated TV shows but top 5 picks for
what those shows are going to be like I
said they're probably gonna be three or
four of them but top 5 picks are number
5 Cindy moon silk who's a character that
was supposed to have a live-action
movies Sony was developing don't know if
that'll actually wind up happening but I
think it's more reasonable to assume
that they would put her on one of these
TV shows and she's a big enough
character that they could do a show
around her and she would work well with
the group of spider-verse characters
that would
team up for whatever big crossover they
do number four is Jessica drew
spider-woman somebody that they haven't
done in the Marvel Universe yet I
actually think that Marvel might have
the rights to her character there were
rumors for a long time that she was
going to be a cameo during spider-man
far from home in the live-action movies
so at some point I think during Marvel
phase four Marvel phase five you'll see
that character pop up number three is
Miguel O'Hara spider-man 2099 I would
kill for a live-action spider-man 2099
series but I will settle for an animated
one because spider-man 2099 the Marvel
2099 universe is so crazy with the
advanced technology the way the city
looks nueva york is very different from
modern-day New York City early
speculation I would just rather see them
do it animated and make it amazing and
crazy Rick and Morty style rather than
do a cheap looking version live action
number two this should be no surprise
they're probably gonna try and do a
live-action spider-gwen TV series she's
probably the most popular female
spider-verse character they've already
talked about doing a spin-off movie for
Hailee Steinfeld spider-gwen from
spider-man into the spider-verse
she's already all over the place in the
animated TV series if you haven't seen
any of those they're geared towards
younger children so a lot of you may not
have seen those before there's been a
lot of spider-gwen on TV already played
by Duff Cameron and people even in fact
wondered when she came on agents of
shield if she was going to be playing a
live action version of spider-gwen
I see you've met my daughter Ruby
CrossFit Tinker Bell's daughter I don't
know that they would use her if they do
a live-action spider-gwen TV series but
I don't think that Hailee Steinfeld
would do a TV series because she's
mostly a film actress in number one pick
of course a Miles Morales live-action TV
show there's no indication that we're
gonna get a Miles Morales movie or a
live-action version of that character on
screen being ultimate spider-man anytime
soon in the next four or five years
that's plenty of time to develop a TV
show get it off the ground then if
that's successful you put him in those
live-action Spiderman Sony movies now I
don't know if he would cross over into
the MCU because you have all the Sony
spider-man stuff that they're doing on
their own then you have all the stuff
that they're doing in the MCU with Peter
Parker
in Kevin Feige so just to be clear all
these live-action spider-verse shows are
a Sony thing Kevin Feige doesn't have
anything to do with it
so you might even see some venom
spin-offs some symbiote action going on
in live-action on these TV shows -
eventually there are way too many really
awesome characters that they're never
gonna have time to get to in any of the
Sony movies or any of the MCU movies so
it just makes sense that they would try
to use the TV shows to fill that gap you
know obviously the big crossover events
that they would probably go for is
starting with a straight-up spider-man
end of the spider-verse crossover then
doing maybe Spider Island may be doing
Clone Saga and then eventually probably
working their way up to Spider gettin
anything within the Marvel Sonne
universe of characters stories that they
could do from spider-man comics but
everybody write your picks for these
live-action TV shows in the comments
which characters do you think are gonna
get their own live-action TV shows we'll
probably find out what the first of
these TV shows is going to be before the
end of the year they'll probably start
shooting it next year meaning they would
try to release it sometime towards the
end of next year or the beginning of the
following year so it might be a couple
years before we see the first of these
live-action spider-verse TV shows but I
will do more videos about it when we get
more information they're just gonna be a
lot more really cool spider-man stuff
happening on TV and in the movies
because we have spider-man 3 and all the
MCU spider-man stuff we have all the
Sony venom stuff that's going on with
those movies and those spin-offs all the
animated spider-man into the
spider-verse movies and now all these
live-action TV shows so it is a really
good time to be a huge spider-man fan
there was a really weird issue that was
happening with YouTube in the past
couple of days I think it's over but
what'll happen is is I'll be doing more
Marvel phase 4 videos this weekend leave
all your video requests in the comments
below especially if you have big
questions about these spider-verse
TV shows everybody click here to learn
about the really awesome news for the
venom sequel and click here for all my
spider-man far from home deleted scenes
in alternate post-credit scenes thank
you so much for watching
everybody stay awesome I'll see you guys
tonight
[Music]